What's up everybody, Daemon here with IGN News.
Christian Bale is in talks to reprise his role as Batman,...
...in DC's upcoming "Justice League" movie.
If a new report from "Latino Review" is to be believed,...
...Christopher Nolan will oversee the project...
...and "Man of Steel" director Zack Snyder will produce and possibly direct.
The website claims that Nolan is now in charge of the entire DC Universe at Warner Bros...
...and is in discussions to act as a sort of "godfather" to the project.
The studio allegedly wants the film to be set in the same universe...
...as Nolan's "Dark Knight" trilogy,...
...which naturally means a return of Bale's Batman.
Not only that, but "Justice League" would also tie in with Snyder's gritty "Man of Steel"...
...which means, you guessed it,...
...Bale's Batman and Henry Cavill's Superman would appear in the same universe...
...in the same movie at the same time.
Bale wouldn't be against reprising the role as long as the story was right.
"I would love the challenge of making a fourth one work,"...
...he told "Empire Magazine" last summer.
Considering Marvel hit the billion-dollar jackpot with "The Avengers,"...
...Warner Bros. is certainly imagining what it could achieve...
...by crossing over its top two DC properties.
"Avengers" is the third highest grossing movie of all time.
If "Justice League" is released in 2015 as planned,...
...it will go up against "The Avengers 2" in the same year.
As soon as we know more about Batman, "Justice League", and all things DC Universe...
...we'll let you know right here at IGN.